mais d'abord comment les candidates et
les candidats font campagne à la
campagne jérôme rabier
du centre à la droite le vote rural est
convoité est pas un candidat ne peut se
passer de l'image de déplacement à la
ferme même s'il n'est pas encore déclaré
emmanuel macron n'y échappe pas pendant
deux jours il va parler ruralité en
creuse et en haute-vienne dépeint comme
le président des villes emmanuel macron
tente de casser cette image qui est
pourtant corroborée par les scores dans
marche aux élections plus élevé dans les
grands centres urbains pour ne pas
laisser le terrain aux autres sicard
marine le pen par exemple y est en
terrain conquis fort de bons résultats
dans les territoires plus ruraux la
candidate du rassemblement national
privilégient souvent les meetings ou les
sorties dans ces petites villes si
nombreux en france eric zemmour cible
aussi cette france qu'il considère comme
oubliée il l'a répété récemment lors
d'un déplacement en eure-et-loir
ici
même si la ruralité n'est pas limité à
l'agriculture ce thème est souvent mise
en avant par les candidats lors de ses
déplacements en milieu rural en visite
dans le doubs la semaine dernière
valérie pécresse n'a pas oublié son
message au monde agricole
qui salissent le métier et l'honneur des
agriculteurs et je resterai la craie
certaines des déclarations d'amour au
monde rural qui devrait culminer comme
chaque année lors du salon de
l'agriculture du 26 février au 6 mars un
mois avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
présidentielle existe-t-il un vote rural
on en débat tout de suite avec mes
invités anne nivat bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste auteur
de la france de face c publié chez
fayard nathalie noiret bonsoir moi aussi
j'en dise politique au sein du groupe
ebra qui possède plusieurs titres de
presse régional le progrès mais dernière
de tous les républicains par exemple
benjamin morel bonsoir bienvenue maître
de conférences en droit public à paris
ii et vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques
on accueille aussi également en
visioconférence en duplex cécile gallien
qui est maire de vorey sur arzon en
haute-loire
1470 habitants l'hiver et le double
l'été heureux de vous accueillir bon
soit on s'était croisé lors du congrès
des maires de france et évidemment
matthieu croissandeau bonsoir mathieu
non mais comme chaque lundi et mercredi
litoria liste politique on vient de voir
dans le sujet j'aime m'habiller
plusieurs candidats en campagne passage
obligé de la delà de la frontière où
j'ai envie d'y reviendront à la france
éternelle un peu je sais pas comment
vous le ressentez les uns et les autres
ont la france des paysans elle est
souvent là dans le discours des
politiques d'une certaine façon aller je
commence avec vous elle est souvent là
et c'est pas que pour parler justement à
cette france rurale qu'on emploie c'est
à dire que derrière vous charriez toute
une symbolique sur ce qu'est la france
sur ce qu'elle devrait être ou sur vos
pont ou sur ce que vous pensez ce cas
les causses calais ou plutôt sur ce que
vos électeurs pensent que ce qu'est la
france est donc là c'est assez
merci il ya tout un sujet sur grosso
modo quel est le modèle français que
vous visez et donc pour un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui veut
parler justement de cette france
éternelle aller dans la ruralité c'est
envoyer un message
après ça envoyé mais ça un message
également un électorat mais cet
électorat il est en réalité assez
diverses ou de mendier est ce qu'il ya
un vote rural en réalité il ya plusieurs
vote ruraux vous avez un vote
traditionnellement et puis je ne sais
pas dans cette maison que je vais la
prendre et bien qui est plutôt orienté
grosso modo gaulle aux chiraquiens c'est
ce qui est l'un des éléments structurels
qui conduit à rendre structurel le vote
de droite au sénat la surreprésentation
de ces territoires mais on a aujourd'hui
défaut de fondamentalement des
évolutions c'est à dire qu'on a une
campagne des zones rurales plutôt riche
qui vote plutôt centre au droit des
zones au contraire est bien plus tôt en
rupture qui s'orientent peu à peu vers
un vote et rennes on a vu que 30 % aux
dernières élections pouvaient s'orienter
vers le vote n mais ça n'est pas encore
des territoires c'est à dire que le vote
rural en bretagne n'est pas le même que
le vote rural dans le massif central
vous avez une grande grande diversité
avec y puiser des changements
sociologiques le vote rural n'est pas
stable vous avez tout un phénomène
également donné on va y arriver journée
reviendra en traîne tout d'un coup des
émotions électorale anne nivat vous avez
choisi pour pour se livrer dans des
villes de moins de cinquante mille
habitants pourquoi cela parce qu'elles
sont très intéressants parce qu'il faut
bien y aller parce que c'est ça la
france ce que la france et pas
simplement paris lyon marseille ce n'est
pas simplement les banlieues ce n'est
pas simplement les commentaires des
éditorialistes sur les plateaux de
télévision la france est diverse la
france est compliqué à comprendre et les
fractures et je ne prétends pas l'avoir
comprise mais ce que je prétends oui
c'est être allé rencontrer des français
des français qui m'ont tous ouvert leurs
portes même en période de confinement et
j'allais dire comme je voulais dit au
maquillage
période de confinement parce que
justement il n'y avait pas d'autre
endroit où aller dont qui m'accueillait
chez eux pour qu'on puisse parler donc
peut-être était-il plus porter la
confidence je ne sais pas en tout cas
qu'ils soient ruraux ou qu'il ne soit
pas ruraux qu'ils soient de droite ou
qu'ils soient de gauche
le je crois que ce qui est en commun
c'est une espèce de perplexité voire un
dégoût par rapport au spectacle que
donne la politique aujourd'hui où le mot
à huy le moins fort mais vous aviez le
moins fort il y avait un peu la même
démarche ya cinq ans vous aviez vous
êtes tout à fait est ce que est ce que
se dit bouge ça empire et je voudrais en
moins et donc j ai il ya cinq ans
j'avais publié un livre qui s'appelle
dans quelle france on vit qui était
volontairement publié au moment de
l'élection qui a donné comme président
emmanuel macron et aujourd'hui mon idée
c'était de poursuivre pour voir
justement si ça avait changé et aussi
macron allait être la proie entre
guillemets du dégagisme qui était le
grand événement de l'élection précédente
mais si vous voulez moi je ne suis pas
là pour dire quel est l'homme politique
ou la femme politique qui va s'en sortir
le mieux je ne suis personne ça m'est
totalement égal moi ce qui m'importe
c'est essayer de comprendre justement ce
que les français ont à dire et ce qu'ils
ont à dire c'est c'est difficile à
entendre c'est franchement difficile à
entendre c'est difficile à croire mais
je ne suis pas quand même la seule aller
parler aux français on le sait alors par
exemple j'ai jeff au café des sports qui
tient le café des sports à fégréac
puisqu'on est là pour parler de la
ruralité à fégréac en loire-atlantique
qui me disait quelque chose qui je crois
va intéresser la mère avec qui vous avez
prévu de faire un duplex puisqu'il
disait le commerce est dématérialisé je
crois bien que la sociabilité aussi et
lui la peur qu'un jour y est même plus
de mer c'est à dire il dit ça sera comme
la banque on n'aura plus d'interlocuteur
on sera complètement
d'interlocuteurs en chair en os on
s'attend paiement dans le virtuel ça
c'est un danger c'est quelque chose qui
fait peur à tout le monde le danger de
la communication aussi à une obligation
des politiques on y reviendra évidemment
bah tiens justement parce que vous
m'offrez la transition joie
cécile gallien c'est moi ça me fait
penser à une publicité pour une banque
justement où il ya un client qui cherche
désespérément à voir quelqu'un de de
plus de philippe une vraie personne au
bout du fil un maire un maire qui
disparaît remplacé par un page pas c'est
une vision d'horreur belle vision
d'horreur évidemment mais c'est une
vision d'horreur mais rassurez-vous
enfin je fus un rassurez vous je
l'espère les maires vous continuez à
être au service des habitants et je peux
vous dire que la commune la mienne est
ouverte six jours sur sept et elle ne
désemplit pas du lundi au samedi pour
diverses questions mais tous par exemple
le mangement monfils n'a pas trouvé de
stage par exemple
j'ai des difficultés sociales par
exemple un porteur de projet qui vient
s'installer en couple cherchant un
hectare pour développer de
l'agrotourisme donc on doit y répondre
par exemple industriel
qui ont 100 à des difficultés sur lequel
il faut aider à ce que du plan de
relance puissent les voilà donc je ne
pense pas que enfin c'est sûr que la
présence des maires est tout à fait
indispensable vous pouvez pas vous
imaginer je moi j'incite tous les
français à se présenter aux élections
municipales et à venir donner la main en
dévouement pour servir les autres c'est
ce qu'on fait dans nos communes rurales
mais ce que j'entends dans votre
témoignage cécile gallien c'est beaucoup
de deux demandes qui passe par les
maires mais est-ce que vous avez
forcément les leviers pour répondre à
ces demandes
alors écoutez moi j'ai été élu il ya 13
ans l'objectif c'était trouver un
médecin parce que un
exercice plus et l'autre était bientôt à
la retraite on a fait les sorties de fac
il ya 13 ans n'est pas arrivé donc on a
on a mis une annonce grâce à la région
auvergne à l'époque sur internet et on a
eu trois candidatures de médecins
étrangers on a ainsi installé un
européen il ya dix ans et il ya cinq ans
on a installé une jeune qui est devenue
médecin qui était du coin qui est venu
s'installer dans la maison de santé donc
il faut de toute façon quoi qu'il en
soit dépensé in her une énergie folle
une énergie humaine folle avec des
moyens des plus limités pour répondre et
anticiper les choses je voudrais dire
une chose aussi la ruralité c'est
l'espace aujourd'hui il serait temps de
considérer que l'espace est une richesse
la sécurité alimentaire l'air l'eau les
identités culturelles
tentante et si bien que même la
commission européenne en juin dernier a
décidé de travailler sur une vision
globale et positive des territoires
ruraux il existe des agendas urbain
européen il n'existait pas 2 d'agenda
ruraux européen eh bien ça va exister en
tout cas en france on en a décliné en
2019 j ai travaillé et je peux vous dire
que la france la nation l'europe le
monde ne peuvent pas se passer d espace
rural c'est impossible je reviens vers
vous tous évidemment
on vit dans une vitrine pour paris je
vais pas vous contredire je reviens vers
vous dans l'instant j'essaye de
distribuer la parole un peu un peu
équitablement et d'entendre tout le
monde nathalie morel est ce que est ce
qu'il ya un peu
deux temps et c'est sans doute binaire
ce que je vais vous poser comme question
mais deux temps de vision de cette
campagne présidentielle puisqu'on était
avec les candidats en campagne vision
très parisienne reprend un product
design lui appuie la vision des lecteurs
de vos quotidiens finalement et pas
forcément la même voyez ce que je veux
dire l'intérêt pour la campagne est ce
que j'espérais parisien est un peu
surévalué par rapport à l'intérêt des
français à l'instant t 1 je suis pas
totalement certaine mois pour travailler
dans dans des quotidiens régionaux
depuis toujours j'ai pas le sentiment
que ce qui me les gens qui habitent dans
les régions et pas dans les territoires
parce que je vous rappelle que quand on
habite en région on n'habite pas dans
des territoires ça sert mieux c'est un
mot pour l'instant fin aux parisiens
s'étaient parisien bien je n'en faisais
tout à l'heure dans les titres mais
désolé mais ce qui intéresse les gens
effectivement qui vivent à lyon à
strasbourg ou à lons le saunier c'est à
peu près la même chose que ce qui
intéresse les gens qui vivent à corbeil
essonnes où dans le 11e arrondissement
il ya aussi partout des problématiques
qui sont qui sont partagés donc je
dirais oui et non non parce
qu'effectivement il ya des
problématiques partager et oui parce
qu'il ya un certain parisianisme et
toutes les décisions qui viennent d'en
haut sont souvent assez mal vécu et tout
tout le travail des candidats à la
présidentielle c'est pendant les
quelques mois qui arrivent enfin les
quelques mois qui précède l'élection
c'est justement de gommer ce
parisianisme là rappelez-vous durant
l'année qui vient de s'écouler on a vu
tous les candidats faire un tour de
france pour aller à la rencontre des
gens comme si le reste du temps c'était
difficile il y aller et d'être à la
pêche aux bonnes idées on a vu anne
hidalgo ce faire ça on a vu fabien
roussel faire ça cet été le président
macro lui il a fait tout le temps depuis
son élection parce qu'on va peut-être en
reparler mais on entend très présent sur
sur le terrain donc voilà il ya pour
répondre à votre question c'est oui et
non les problématiques peuvent être les
mêmes mais en même temps c'est vrai qu'
un parisianisme qui peut être mal vu
alors justement cette étiquette mathieu
c'est intéressant parce que
emmanuel macron président des villes ça
c'est une étiquette qui a la vie dure
elle lui colle à la peau ça tient tout
d'abord à une raison de sociologie
électorale faut rappeler qu'en 2017 il a
fait un très gros scores dans les
centres urbains rendant dans les villes
de l'avait d'ailleurs fait campagne
essentiellement dans les centres urbains
pour vous donner une idée c'est dans les
villes de plus de 5000 habitants il est
récolté 1 en moyenne six points de plus
que la moyenne nationale al'inverse
selon le site est tout à leur marine le
pen elle a plutôt fait un bon score dans
les zones rurales ça tient aussi à sa
formation classe préparatoire au lycée
henri iv sciences po paris l'ena dans
l'imaginaire collectif c'est un pur
produit de la capitale on en oublierait
presque qu'il a passé son enfance à
amiens il le dit il le disait un 2e en
2010 est moi je suis un enfant de la
province et semble un peu oublié puis ça
tient enfin à son parcours professionnel
et politique si j'ose dire il n'a jamais
été élu mais ne la crois capable d'
ancrage local d'ancrage territorial il a
été banquier d'affaires puis ministre
puis président déroule un cv très
citadin très parisien et puis surtout
son exercice du pouvoir extrêmement
verticale très centralisé très jacobin
et la colère que ça a généré dans l'oeil
à la france on dit la france des
territoires oubliés les petits faut pas
oublier cette expression celle des
gilets jaunes ont racheté de le
caricaturer en prédisant des vides et
forcément ses adversaires ils auraient
tort de s'en priver il exploite oui dans
une deuxième forme de procès qui
ressemble pour beaucoup d'entre eu quand
même un procès en sorcellerie car enfin
gérer marine le pen elle est née à
neuilly sur seine a passé les trente
premières années de sa vie politique
dans l'ouest parisien avant de se
parachuter dans le pas de calais valérie
pécresse est l'aîné ou à
neuilly-sur-seine l'a fait carrière dans
les yvelines et puis elle est maintenant
en prison de la région ile de france
prenez eric zemmour il est né à
montreuil il a grandi à drancy m'enfin
il n'a jamais vécu ailleurs qu'à paris
mais voilà ça les empêche pas d'en faire
des tonnes soit encore dans le figaro
valérie pécresse dit le prise en main
crottin présidence sans racines voilà
eric ciotti son rival malheureux à la
primaire il ya trois semaines 10 est
carrément que emmanuel macron n'aimez
pas la france ils étaient déracinées
on se dit qu est-ce qui jouent derrière
enfin au nom de quoi on peut décréter
qu'un candidat aime ou n'aime pas la
france on voit bien que l'idée c'est de
faire un présent urbain mondialistes
santerre face à une terre qui elle
forcément ne ment pas comme dirait
l'autre et avec des relents un petit peu
pétainiste vous souvenez de cette
affiche sous l'occupation êtes vous plus
français que lui demander ton avec la
tête du maréchal pétain et est donc
emmanuel macron effort n'est pas tout à
fait pas revenus à corriger cette image
non il s'est pris un peu tard à coup de
grands débats en 2019 de tour de france
on les allusions en 2021 et sur phase
arrêtée quand même beaucoup déplacé sur
le terrain rendez vous compte à l'été
2020 il nomme le maire de prades jean
castex pour renouer le lien avec avec
les territoires essayer de dépasser
cette image un peu trop parisienne mais
dans les faits c'est un paradoxe est que
dans les faits son quinquennat aura été
plutôt plus favorable à la ruralité et
la banlieue si on prend l'essentiel des
mesures ou des sommes qui ont été
alloués mais voilà il ya toujours cette
image comme quoi c'est difficile à
tordre son plus grand échec à mes yeux
restera quand même l'échec de son parti
en marche parce que ça aussi ça aurait
pu faciliter la vie on a encore des élus
en marche qui son caractère a caricaturé
en parlementaire bon technicien mais
absolument pas ancrée sur les fameux
territoire et c'est pas à moins de deux
mois deux films de la présidentielle ont
varié qui va réussir à redresser cette
image rails en tout cas cette
implantation benjamin morel
vous faisiez signe pendant la chronique
j'irai lire le ciel c'est d'accord avec
la critique je rajouterais peut-être
deux choses alors il faut du temps pour
implanter en partie il n'y a pas eu la
volonté d' emmanuel macron de vraiment
construire ce parti même pas non plus
oublier que les gaullistes met 20 à 30
ans à s'implanter réellement sur les
territoires mais malgré tout de gaulle
avait une volonté c'est à dire que lui
d'air etc ce sont des machines à gagner
les élections la république en marche
n'est pas devenu ça le deuxième élément
que dont emmanuel macron et bien je
dirais est la résultante et qui lui pose
problème c'est qu'il ya pas de carrière
politique derrière c'est à dire que même
si françois hollande même si de l'autre
côté jacques chirac avait en réalité un
profil originellement très parisien ils
ont su construire localement une
carrière et ils ont su construire les
taux ce qu'était un ethos liées
justement à leur lieu d'élection lié à
l'endroit où grosso modo il pouvait
parler à la france est d'où il pouvait
parler à la france valéry giscard
d'estaing qui a priori apparaît quand
même comme étant le symbole du
technocrates parisiens mais qui fait son
annonce de candidature depuis
chamalières dans le puy-de-dôme ça ça
signifie quelque chose d'un ancrage avec
un territoire d'une salle signifie
quelque chose pour l'électorat qui en
fait implique que vous n'êtes pas qu'un
parisien vous venez de quelque part et
vous raconter une histoire qui vient de
ce territoire là emmanuel macron n'a pas
pu produire ça avant alors certes il a
grandi à amiens mais comme il n'a pas
été élu avant comme n'a pas été député
comme n'a pas été maire il a pas eu
cette histoire à raconter et cette
histoire vous n'inventez pas en un
quinquennat anne nivat vous avez posé la
question macron aux français vous avez
rencontré rit beaucoup et parfois la
question macron arrive sans qu'on la
pose finalement et je dois dire
d'ailleurs que alors zemmour n'était pas
encore candidat quand j'étais en ans
qu'elles m'ont se livre donc il n'est
pas mention dans mon livre ii de eric
zemmour il est mention beaucoup de
marine le pen aussi de jean luc
mélenchon est en fait à chaque fois
souvent non pas à chaque fois
quelquefois quand mes interlocuteurs me
parler de macron c'est le sel
personnalités politiques avec laquelle
on se permettait quelques familiarités
de langage c'est à dire que macron le
nomme souvent par un surnom on ne disait
pas macron on me disait le beau gosse le
prince
le microbe c'est peut-être moi écouter
une fois de plus je ne juge pas mais en
tout cas ça se défend des accusations
que ce soit en négatif on tape affaire
de la milliardaire aussi en tout cas
c'est la façon dont certaines personnes
on tape les emmanuel macron mais je
pense que et alors je repense justement
à une éleveuse de chèvres à fégréac
toujours de chèvre bio manu 30 la
trentaine qui me disait puisque vous
demandez qui m'a parlé maintenant qu'
elle m'a dit elle est assez éloigné de
la politique donc indifférente à la
politique c'est ce qu'elle dit elle-même
mais ce qu'elle avait voulu me dire
c'est que macron à son avis une fois de
plus je ne juge pas ce qu'elle dit je
leur apporte n'avait été élu que par 30
% de la population en fin de compte ce
qu'elle veut dire par là c'est qu'il a
été mal élu ce qu'elle veut dire par là
c'est que quel que soit le nouveau
président le nouveau chef d'état il sera
mal élu parce que justement il y a une
espèce de désaffection non pas de la
chose politique parce que tout le monde
aime la politique tout le monde aime
participer à la vie de la cité mais de
ceux de la théâtralisation de la mise en
scène de la com permanente qui est
aujourd'hui campagne électorale puisque
on parlait tout à l'heure de mac ronde
en limousin et mais moi j'aime enfin ce
que je veux dire là est impossible mais
plutôt que d'être tout le temps en train
de regarder des images de femmes et
hommes politiques qui sont sur nous dans
nos terroirs pour ne pas dire territoire
en train de faire campagne et bien
effectivement et sicile s'il pouvait y
aller ici il y allait sans les médias
derrière c'est à dire sans être vu sans
que tout ce qu'ils font soit analysée
décortiquée et surtout utilisé
immédiatement c'est à dire que être vu
quelque part aujourd'hui c'est déjà
d'accord et aujourd'hui c'était un petit
peu à mon sens limite si c'est à cela
que se résume notre campagne hélas une
fois de plus les français ne sont pas
dupes
un petit coup d'oeil aux votes à
l'élection présidentielle
source ipsos sopra steria pour public
sénat c'était au mois de mai 2017 on
retrouve les scores des manuels macro et
marine le pen le score total ça rejoint
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
mathieu dans les villes de moins de 5000
habitants c'est intéressant jusqu'à
20000 habitants on est à peu près au
même niveau on est à 65 35 ans nancy on
descend là effectivement on arrive à un
score de mâcon qui baisse à 57% marine
le pen à
43% est ce que vous diriez que et
peut-être que vous le ressentez dans
dans les études que vous menez dans les
reportages que vous faites nathalie
morin est ce que vous diriez que le vote
extrémiste il est lié à un sentiment de
déclassement très souvent et que ça
rejoint peut-être cette vision d'une
carte de france qui plus on se rapproche
de la réalité plus on se rapproche mais
vous avez totalement raison et ça il
suffit pas d'être enfin tout où toutes
les études l'ont prouvé et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que healy a autant de
moi ce qui me frappe c'est
qu'effectivement dans la campagne à
campagne présidentielle actuelle il ya
un certain nombre de candidats qui sont
13 à l'extrême droite et à l'extrême
gauche qui justement vont chercher ces
gens là qui quand ils ont voté ont voté
majoritairement aux extrêmes mais qui
aussi vous pouvez regarder la carte de
l'abstention
l'abstention aussi est aussi beaucoup
dans ces zones là pourquoi parce que
sans être peut-être délaissé mais en
tous les cas c'est des endroits où il ya
moins de services publics c'est les
endroits où les écoles ferment c'est les
endroits où il faut parfois quitter sa
région pour trouver du travail c'est un
endroit où il ya une désertification et
une désindustrialisation
donc oui c'est sont des endroits où les
votes extrêmes sont les plus importants
et quand ils ne sont pas extrêmes où on
est dans le non vote et c'est tout c'est
très intéressant de regarder
qu'actuellement justement eric zemmour
marine le pen nicolas dupont aignan qui
a présenté son programme aujourd'hui
tous tous tous font énormément de
propositions pour ces gens là qui sont
en dehors du vote
j'ai moi mais moi je peux tout
simplement pas laisser dire que le vote
extrême est lié à la réalité ça ça mon
avis ça n'est pas entendre il n'existe
pas que dans les
vide absolu il est si j'écris le
laissait entendre ça c'était actif je
l'espère on a d'un point de vue
électoral trois éléments qui se
télescopent en granit est d'abord vous
avez une population structurellement
plus âgées ce qui paradoxalement est pas
très favorable au vote et rennes et ça
constitue en réalité la base de droit
douloureux chirac et de traditionnel
ensuite vous avez une population au wat
déclassement parce que vous avez en
effet du problème pour trouver du
travail etc il ya pas moins de médecins
à la campagne par habitant que en ville
y en a même plus en réalité mais les
distances sont beaucoup plus grande et
donc vous avez ce sentiment de
déclassement qui peut pousser à une
forme de vote extrême et ensuite vous
avez une nouvelle population rurale je
parlais tout à l'heure des néoruraux
souvent des gens qui sont dans la
moralité viennent à la ruralité parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de vivre en
ville et donc vous avez le déclassement
également de la ville je vais vivre
justement dans un pavillon péri urbains
ou néorural parce qu'en réalité je
travaille en centre ville et j'ai pas
les moyens de me loger et donc tout ça
crée évidemment des difficultés qui sont
exploitées ensuite par des candidats qui
joue dessus et qui font plutôt de bons
scores aux chiffres en témoignent alors
qu'on parle maintenant vous l'avait déjà
évoqué cécile gallien effet également
des des déserts médicaux parce que ça
peut être une illustration de cette
france à deux vitesses en temps par
steve journée un peu me rejoindre tout
de suite bonsoir samariens bienvenus
on va évidemment entrer dans le détail
un peu d des propositions et des
informations sur cette idée déserts
médicaux peut-être que c'est plus
compliqué imaginez notre cas c'est une
question qui intéresse ou qui va
intéresser un certain nombre de
candidats à l'élection présidentielle a
fortiori en cette période de crise
sanitaire alors quelques éléments de
contexte peut être thomas les déserts
médicaux cela concerne aujourd'hui une
commune sur trois et pas seulement les
communes qu'on dit rural ça concerne
aussi des communes situées en périphérie
des grandes villes on estime qu entre 9
et 12% de la population française vit
aujourd'hui dans un désert médical on
parle là de 6 à 8 millions de personnes
autre donnée intéressante ces déserts
médicaux et bien engendre un coût qui
pourrait atteindre jusqu'à 5 milliards
d'euros par an pour le système de santé
quand ya pas de médecin de ville où on
va et bien on appelle les pompiers ou
bien on vient on va à l'hôpital hôpital
qui se retrouve alors et bien rapidement
engorgé cette situation thomas ne
s'atténue pas ces dernières années bien
au contraire selon un sondage bva
63% des français auraient déjà renoncé
au moins une fois à se faire soigner la
conséquence elle est très concrète la
carte des déserts médicaux et bien se
superpose à celle de la mortalité sont
un rapport du sénat les 5 % de français
les plus aisés ont aujourd'hui une
espérance de vie de 13 ans supérieur aux
5 % des français les plus pauvres et si
on cherche à faire un bilan du
quinquennat des mêmes maquereau en la
matière peut mieux faire mais alors là
il n'est pas le seul concerné parce que
eh bien tous les présidents avant lui
bien se sont heurtés à cette question de
l'accès aux soins regarder depuis
l'année 2004 loi ont été adoptés de
plans santé ont été lancés un
enchaînement de réformes qui n'enraye
pas donc on l'aura compris
l'augmentation de ces inégalités
dernière réforme en date c'est celle de
2019 c'est la réforme busin l acte
notamment cette réforme la fin du
numerus clausus ce qui devrait permettre
et bien d'augmenter le nombre de
médecins formés chaque année mais de
l'aveu même de l'ancien ministre de la
santé et bien ça ne va pas suffire
écoutez la nous allons annoncer une
réforme du système de santé qui vise à
rapprocher
les français des soins de proximité ou
plutôt de rapprocher les soins de
proximité des français dans les
territoires donc le numerus clausus et
améliorer le bien-être étudiants faire
en sorte qu on diversifie
le profil des personnes qui vont rentrer
dans les études de médecine qu'on ne les
sélectionne pas uniquement sur les maths
et la physique
donc c'est la mesure que nous
annoncerons la fin du numerus clausus
mais il ne faut pas que les français
imaginent que cela résoudra du jour au
lendemain le problème des déserts
médicaux qui doit être réglé dès
aujourd'hui ce constat est évidemment
partagé par le sénateur des sénateurs
qui défendent le principe de la liberté
d'établissement des médecins des
sénateurs qui refuse donc et bien de
forcer les médecins à aller s'installer
là où on aurait pourtant plutôt besoin
de te merci steve pour toutes ces
précisions cécile gallien vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
comprendre comment ça s'est passé quand
vous êtes battus pour faire venir
des médecins d'abord un médecin dans
votre commune est ce que vous étiez en
concurrence est ce que c'était la
bagarre avec d'autres communes
limitrophes ou es ce que vous avez eu
niveau force comment ça s'est passé
en fait gérés en fait je voulais dit on
a lancé une annonce sur internet parce
qu'on a ça en a fait la sortie des facs
de médecine de saint-etienne de clermont
de lyon donc c'était il ya onze ans
personne ne voulait venir donc on à moi
j'ai réuni les acteurs en force c'est à
dire la maison de retraite le pharmacien
les infirmières et on a accueilli un
premier médecin qu'on a trouvé par
internet on lui a donné envie de venir
s'installer c'était un médecin européen
je le redis il a trouvé que le coin
était sympa que s'ils avaient des
enfants il pourrait lui mettre à la
crèche que les gens étaient sympathiques
que le paysage était plutôt chouette qui
avait une communauté d'élus mais aussi
d'acteurs professionnels de services à
la personne et de soins qui lui donner
envie de venir s'installer donc ensuite
on a créé une maison de santé etc et
maintenant on a une communauté on va
dire 2 deux professionnels de santé
alors on a aussi les ederer on est en
zone de revitalisation rurale c'est très
important de maintenir là où il le faut
absolument sur les communes rurales ces
possibilités d'exonération pendant 5 8 8
ans de voilà d'impôt sur le revenu mais
c'est pas je pense que en fait moi j'ai
pas envie de vous laisser dire que y'a
plus personne qui lit à habiter à la
campagne et c'est celle inverse avant le
coc vide on sentait déjà qu'ils avaient
plus de français qui choisissez la
campagne et alors avec l'effet corrie
nous n'avons plus au sud aucune maison à
vendre quand vous habitez à la campagne
chez nous vous avez une crèche vous avez
des assistantes maternelles vous ne
devez pas vous dire ah tiens je vais
tomber enceinte et deux en avants se
dire il faut que je reste dans ma classe
mama places à la crèche c'est absolument
pas comme ça chez nous vous trouvez des
places dans les crèches dont il faut
arrêter de dire que les campagnes se
dépeuplent s'il faut regarder les
regarder l'insee je vous invite à le
faire alors je dis pas que c'est idéal
partout il ya du rural profond mais
aussi des territoires qui sont
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus industrialisés
que les métropoles nous nous avons eu
des industries depuis 100 ans et nous
arrivons à maintenir les emplois ou à
les développer nous faisons du nous
accueillons les touristes depuis 100 ans
arrêtons de dire que le rural est un
rural perdu c'est absolument faux et sur
les néo ruraux il s'installe pas à une
heure de paris uniquement ou alors et
des métropoles ils viennent aussi chez
moi à quatre heures de paris parce que
y'a le train parce qu'aujourd'hui grâce
au new deal on a maintenant un téléphone
portable depuis quatre ans par tous qui
passe on a dû du développement
d'internet parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous accueillez les jeunes
aussi qui ont plein de compétences qui
ont besoin juste d'un ordinateur et
d'une mobilité correct pour pouvoir
développer leurs compétences et
travailler à distance c'est à dire ça va
commencer avant richter pardon vous
interromps de jean reprend la même
seconde ça avait commencé avant la crise
alitée ou c'est vraiment un mouvement
lié notamment au développement du
télétravail
ça avait déjà commencé avant la crise
sanitaire cette envie de campagne parce
qu'en fait les français disent deux
choses à la fois les territoires ruraux
sont parfois oubliés mais à la fois ça
serait mon mon lieu de vie idéal en
famille en fête et on se rende compte
que les choses ont avancé
et maintenant à la campagne on a
tellement d'offres d'emploi dans les
restaurants dans les industries dans les
administrations dans les services d'aidé
à la personne et nous manque du monde
pour venir vivre et travailler au pays
et paysans ça veut dire pays ça veut
dire de l'habitant des paillis des
territoires des régions de france qui
font la diversité la richesse de cette
cette belle france
merci de ce témoignage année un mot très
court là dessus parce que je ne peux pas
être plus d'accord avec ce que madame
l'avez ressenti un dénommé avant de
complètement raison et sané ap je ne
pensais pas devoir écrire là dessus dans
mon livre mais finalement j'ai des
chapitres entiers là dessus dans deux
chapitres par exemple dans le diois
c'est à dire dans la drôme derrière la
ville de 10 j'ai été dans un village qui
s'appelle miss qu'on 240 habitants un
bourg qui s'appelle recoupent bojan sac
là c'est pareil il ne cesse d'avoir des
nouveaux arrivants et ses nouveaux
arrivants ne recherche pas à sortir de
la ville comme vous l'avez dit parce que
c'est trop cher il cherche à sortir de
la ville pour avoir une meilleure
qualité de vie et ça c'est trop cher non
c'est un choix de vie c'est un choix de
vie ça n'est pas exclusivement parce que
c'est trop cher et comme il ya des
français ils sont très nombreux qui
n'ont plus envie de vivre en ville on
sait tous qu'il y a des chiffres qui
montrent que la ville de paris est en
train de perdre des habitants il ya des
il ya et il y à un autre chapitre dans
mon livre qui est à andernos les bains
où je traite d'un autre sujet et qui est
le rapport à nos vieux à la vieillesse
et je ne pensais pas que ça serait à ce
point là c'est à dire j'étais dans un
hôtel et les personnes qui faisaient
totalement dit il n'y a pas un jour qui
se passe sans que nos clients soient
quelqu'un qui vient ici parce que il est
en train d'acheter une maison ils chez
nous parce que les travaux sont en train
d'être faits le maire qui est un ancien
amant un jean moulin immobilier et qui
lui sait représenter en 2020 qui a été
réélu parce qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autre
candidat qui est un homme très
sympathique monsieur rosa de ça m'a dit
l'a confirmé il a dit que c'était
absolument un phénomène qui est là
depuis longtemps c'est à dire que en est
là andernos les bains on est dans le
fond du bassin d'arcachon il y a donc ce
phénomène extrêmement fort et qui n'est
pas uniquement dû aux critères qui
étaient les critères disons plus
traditionnels il ya quelques années
benjamin morel ça ce mouvement de
population ça veut dire aussi une
recomposition des du vote et des cartes
électorales peloton alors c'est à dire
que pour l'instant il faut nuancer ce
moment de population on a du mouvement
du centre-ville vers le périurbain le
grand enjeu c'est d'envoyer du mouvement
périurbain vers le milieu réellement
rural hélas implique d'avoir des bassins
d'emplois dynamiques d'avoir des
transports et des services publics qui
le sont c'est nécessaire en réalité
c'est à dire qu'on est un pays
extrêmement déséquilibrée aujourd'hui
entre centre ville et périphérie et y
compris d'un point de vue
environnemental sont des politiques
publiques qu'il faut penser sur le très
long terme de toute façon dès le moment
où vous avez des évolutions de
population
vous avez évidemment des évolutions
électorale le monde rural tel qu'on le
connaissait c'est à dire plutôt
conservateur de droit de gaulle aux
chiraquiens pour faire simple était lié
à une sociologie particulière était liée
à la fois au poids de l'église était
liée au poids d'un certain nombre de
traditions acceptera tout ça des moments
où vous avez une nouvelle population
évidemment déjà ça s'éteint en partie
mais ça c'est un réellement donc on a
des recompositions on le voit dans
certaines communes rurales qui tout d'un
coup bascule politiquement avec une
sociologie du vote qui se transforme
donc c'est également encore une fois
important pour cette maison dans lequel
vous avez des petites communes qui sont
sur représentés du point de vue
politique en tout cas ça ne change pas
ça ne change pas encore une fois grand
chose à ce que pour les candidats comme
on disait au départ qui parle de la
ruralité l'objectif c'est d'abord le
vote rural sans vote assez fixe en
réalité nous avait pas beaucoup de marge
de manoeuvre qui plus est c'est un vote
jeudi et abstentionnistes mais kate
abstentionnistes dans le périurbain et
pakistan sioniste forcément dans la
campagne profonde et donc à partir de là
vous jouez sur des images beaucoup plus
que vous n'allez chercher des lecteurs
c'est par un vote qui monocolore
non bien sûr que non il y aurait au
bonheur et au times que euros
vous avez dans le
sud ouest le sud ouest bottes plutôt
vous avez un vote plutôt rurale de
gauche vous avez tendance à vous avez
arrêté ma gravissent 60 à lol la
bretagne vous avez un vote de campagne
de centre-droit mais où le rn commence à
percer c'est que quand vous regardez les
dernières élections voyez malgré tout
une poussée du fn au sein même de la
bretagne donc on voit que oui vous avez
grosso modo une couleur des campagnes
entre guillemets différentes selon les
régions mais qui a quand même même si
c'est un peu différent et à des degrés
variables une percée du vote et rennes
qui est assez généralisé alors on va
écouter le prêt dans la république qui
met en avant le l'écart macron vous
souvenez lancé plus tôt début de son
quinquennat est dit que ça a permis de
désenclaver les campagnes manal macron
la première chose que j'ai fait dans ma
vie politique entre guillemets ça a été
les quarts
je me suis battu à l'époque d'ailleurs
je me suis bien fait taper dessus pour
ouvrir le marché des quarts et permettre
que justement des compagnies de cars
secret plus facilement ce qui a permis
dans beaucoup d'endroits de la ruralité
de créer des compagnies de car on peut
mesurer aujourd'hui le résultat de ce
qu'on avait fait il ya maintenant six
ans wemmel macron c'était cet après-midi
dans la creuse est effectivement merci
mathieu pourtant le sonore ou me l'avait
rappelé et c'était quand il était
ministre il avait lancé les les bus
macron cécile gallien au retour de
terrain ça ça a eu un impact dans dans
votre région autour de votre ville et
les bus macron
alors je sais que des jeunes ont choisi
les bisses macro pour monter à paris
parce que ça coûte moins cher que
prendre le train malheureusement que
nous avons nous avons arrêté vers pierre
a pris un tgv alors en mai 7 heures à 8
heures pour monter à paris au lieu de 4
mais ça coûte beaucoup moins cher et ça
permet aussi aux jeunes d'aller à la
capitale de temps en temps parce qu'au
fond dire aussi que les jeunes des
territoires ruraux on vit aussi de voir
ailleurs de temps en temps comme les
gens des villes j'imagine et puis de
revenir voilà je voudrais dire aussi que
c'est important que que les ruraux ils
le sont d'ailleurs enfin en contact avec
d'autres que d'ailleurs si important que
les urbains soit en contact aussi avec
les ruraux pour qu on puisse se
comprendre mieux se comprendre et
comprendre la réalité de nos vies qui
est très différente voilà qui est très
différente de 2,2 de communes hambourg
en ville et en régions mais je je je
fais un lien entre entre la modernité et
les terroirs l'un va avec l'autre c'est
comme ça qu'on est français et c'est
important aussi quand on vit maintenant
à paris de ne pas oublier qu'on a été
provincial dans une première vie et
souvent quand on est journaliste on est
muté à paris voilà et on l'oublié un peu
la première vue on en prend la société
dans la région de bordeaux et c'était et
c'était top la terrible récession si on
termine avec avec peut-être le bilan
macron parce qu'on l'a évoqué avec m
tout à l'heure mais c'est intéressant
d'avoir votre regard là-dessus il n'a
pas arrêté pendant son quinquennat de
sillonner la france est 2e et notamment
la france rurale il n'a pas arrêté vous
en vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure
mathieu je me souviens très bien que il
est élu en 2017 on lui colle cette image
vérifier deux présidents des villes et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait dès 2018 dès la
première année de son mandat il va dans
les territoires ruraux je n'ai pas eu le
temps avant de venir ici mais je vous
lire compter le nombre des exploitations
agricoles qui l'avait qu'il avait
visitée mais c'est colossal je me
souviens qu'il avait été notamment il a
été il est allé plusieurs fois au sommet
de l'élevage dans la région de madame
gallien peu de président la république
l'ont fait les gens vont au salon de
l'agriculture mais pau
au salon d'élevage en auvergne il est
allé très très très souvent voir les
gens étaient là et pourquoi ça n'imprime
pas ça n'imprime pas c'est quand même
assez terrible pour lui parce que c'est
comme il est il pas élu effectivement il
lassé du façon rétinienne on sait qu'il
est le président des métropoles et peu
le président des territoires où il s'est
encore encore une fois beaucoup rendu si
le sens du déplacement d'il ya un mois à
vichy et vierzon celui du limousin
aujourd'hui il n'a cessé de se déplacer
et et mathieu pour conclure jean castex
que vous l'avez rappelé ce choix il
n'était pas fait par hasard ça a pas
malgré tout fait un peu parce que
simpliste elle a persévéré l'on sert à
rien
andy ses fans jean castex fois un élu de
terrain et puis c'est à la fois un haut
fonctionnaire un énarque et on n'a plus
vu crise sanitaire oblige et avec toutes
les décisions à prendre le jean castex
énarque en tant que projet préfet
sanitaire géant aux gardes champêtres
gyan que vous voulez de de l'affairé en
serre que que
que l'élu l'élu de prades après il est
il à sa faconde il a ses réseaux et mais
il n'a pas il n'a pas réussi en tout cas
à retisser un lien fort avec avec les
élus locaux comme comme la mission comme
comme l'y avait confié emmanuel macron
quand il a nommé jean cacher justement
j'ai l'impression plutôt que le choix de
jean castex c'est un très bon binôme
macro castex c'est alors là en terme de
communication requis des tesla comme
mais là on est dans l'excellence parce
que justement on voit là un homme qui a
de la faconde qui quand ils parlent
parlent comme les français je parle de
jean castex et donc on le laisser comme
une espèce de compensation de ce que
pouvaient de l'image que pour être
projetée par emmanuel macron merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat ici à paris et aussi en
haute-loire merci beaucoup cécile
gallien participez à notre débat je
rappelle anne le titre de votre livre la
france de face et publié chez fayard
sens public